[Musique]
cette toute jeune fille découvre
l'environnement militaire à travers la
lecture d'une bande dessinée elle
pourrait aussi bien le faire en
regardant un film une série ou en
utilisant les nouveaux outils numériques
[Musique]
les armées ont toujours été proches des
arcs populaires quelle que soit leur
forme et leur message le journal de la
défense vous emmène dans l'histoire et
les coulisses des relations entre armées
et créateurs
[Musique]
dans les locaux d'un géant de la bande
dessinée Les Éditions d'Argo Patrice
Buendia scenariste intervient sur les BD
de Tanguy Laverdure Gilles La Plagne et
dessinateur on lui doit la série unité
félin les deux auteurs viennent de
signer pour d'Argo en partenariat avec
le ministère des armées le premier volet
d'une nouvelle série d'aventures
militaires qui a germé dans la tête de
ce troisième homme Alexandre par Ringo
en 2019 j'ai réalisé un reportage pour
Paris Match où j'ai suivi
l'armée française sur l'opération
barkhane j'étais embarqué donc pendant
15 jours à bord d'un pick-up avec quatre
membres d'équipage et à côté de moi
pendant tout le toute la mission j'avais
un infirmier qui s'appelait Paco donc on
a sympathisé il m'a expliqué un petit
peu son métier
et à la fin de la mission le
l'expérience était tellement belle que
je leur avais dit il y a de quoi faire
un livre et une bande dessinée sur le
coup ils m'ont pas cru parce que voilà
des paroles de journalistes et du coup
il s'est trouvé que j'ai proposé l'idée
d'argot
à travers le parcours du capitaine
Virginie médecin de guerre à bord d'un
sujet inédit dans la bande dessinée
celui du service de santé des armées
pour sa première mission d'opération
extérieure l'officier de médecine est
affecté au groupement des commandos
parachutistes sur la base de Gao au Mali
la série
ultra réaliste observe de l'intérieur le
fonctionnement de l'armée française le
ministère des armées a d'ailleurs servi
de conseiller technique durant la
conception de la BD en veillant à son
authenticité
une partie non négligeable de notre
lectorat attend une retranscription
précise et juste de cette expérience là
que ce soit l'expérience militaire donc
là en l'occurrence au milieu du GCP à
Gao ou bien sur une base aéronautique et
dans le pilotage des avions donc là on
peut pas se faire des troupes
approximatifs d'être trop léger ce qu'on
est sûr que là une partie du électorale
vous tomberez dessus et le risque dans
ce cas là c'est perdre vraiment
électorat ce qui est le plus important
c'est la documentation parce que nous en
tant que non militaire on peut pas se
rendre sur place donc on est obligé
d'être en contact avec des gens là-bas
pour qu'ils nous fournissent un maximum
de documentation sur les process les
armes les uniformes
là où ils vivent comment ils vivent etc
je me rappelle très bien de ces scènes
où je cherchais le documentation pour
les jumelles à vision nocturne on avait
les jumelles et le casque dissociés mais
on les avait pas accrochés sur le sur le
casque et mon article documentation
quasiment à la fin de l'album donc là il
y avait des trous partout mais on a
réussi quand même à avoir la
documentation en dernier moment
là où il y a un vrai avantage c'est de
travailler avec des gens qui sont sur le
terrain des consultants qu'il a apporté
énormément à notre travail je soumets
toujours mon scénario à mon découpage à
Paco qui est un infirmier du GCP et qui
apporte énormément c'est à dire que bien
évidemment que l'album serait pas du
tout le même s'il n'était pas intervenu
mon rôle dans la BD
au début c'était de relire les scripts
pour revoir la partie santé surtout à la
partie prise en charge des blessés de
guerre est-ce que c'était assez réaliste
est-ce que les gestes étaient bons
est-ce que la manière de prendre en
charge les blessés étaient la bonne et
puis petit à petit à travailler même sur
les vignettes à donner mon avis un petit
peu sur d'autres aspects de la BD et
donc on échangeait par mail très
régulièrement
une coopération fructueuse quand
l'essentiel est préservée le réalisme de
l'œuvre
la BD militaire peut être populaire si
elle n'est pas militariste direction
tombe pas dans une propagande de
grossière qui ne montrerait que des
choses formidables que des que des
parcours facile etc si on montre la
chose militaire dans sa difficulté
je pense que c'est plus susceptible de
toucher le lecteur
[Musique]
Gilles Ciment ancien directeur général
de la Cité internationale de la bande
dessinée à Angoulême et actuel directeur
adjoint de l'établissement de
communication et de production
audiovisuelle de la défense connaît
parfaitement l'histoire des relations
entre la BD et les armées la bande
dessinée a toujours été très proche du
féminaire de l'armée pas toujours
d'ailleurs de façon positive ça peut
être ça peut être pour se moquer comme
le cinéma d'ailleurs
mais ça remonte à très loin puisque au
19e siècle Christophe l'auteur de la
famille fenouillard était également
l'auteur du sapeur camembert un peu plus
tard pendant la Première Guerre mondiale
aussi bien Bécassine que les Pieds
Nickelés ce sont engagés dans le conflit
on nous a vu au front et ils ont
contribué à soutenir le moral de la
population et à faire adhérer la
population à ce qui se passait au front
ça a continué ensuite évidemment avec la
Seconde Guerre mondiale
etc plus récemment on a connu de grands
phénomènes la bande dessinée de
reportages et la bande dessinée
autobiographique je pense par exemple
aux souvenirs d'Alan Coop soldats
américains qui a fait le débarquement et
qui ensuite est resté en France qui a
confié tous ces souvenirs à Emmanuel
Guibert qui en a fait une bande dessinée
extraordinaire qui s'appelle la guerre
d'Alan ou pour le même dessinateur le
photographe qui sont les souvenirs d'un
photographe reporter de guerre en
Afghanistan
le ministère des armées a créé en 2021
le prix des galons de la BD qui vise à
récompenser des ouvrages de bandes
dessinées consacrées au féminaire quel
que soit leur angle et leur traitement
nous avons au ministère des armées la
chance d'avoir une mine d'or ce sont des
images des témoignages et des vidéos de
l'engagement de nos armées à travers les
âges l'établissement de communication et
de production audiovisuelle de la
défense qui produit et archives des
images photographiques et filmées depuis
plus d'un siècle va devenir pour la
première fois une résidence artistique
pour des auteurs de BD
le passé vit aussi quand il est visité
par la création par par la vie
intellectuelle et artistique
contemporaine donc l'idée c'est d'ouvrir
ces archives nos archives à des
créateurs nous avons lancé un appel à
projet pour qu'un auteur de bande
dessinée Vienne travailler sur soi nos
archives soit d'ailleurs le cadre dans
lequel elles sont conservées
c'est-à-dire le fort d'Ivry qui est un
lieu assez assez magique soit
être au contact de nos opérateurs les
qui font des images aujourd'hui et qui
partent en mission en OPEX au Mali ou
ailleurs et qu'il rende compte peut-être
de cette activité là bien d'autres
genres artistiques devraient à terme
bénéficier de cette résidence ça
pourrait être le cas de l'animation
largement exploité par le passé dans des
univers souvent très oniriques entre le
cinéma et la bande dessinée et
l'animation le cinéma d'animation
puisque dans les années 70 et surtout
les années 80 il s'est développé aussi
une activité vraiment de de film
d'animation qui allait chercher des
grands réalisateurs déjà reconnu comme
Rouxel le créateur des Shadoks ou la
Loue le réalisateur primé primaire à
Cannes avec la planète sauvage pour
faire des petits films d'animation de
d'instructions une entreprise c'est
comme un être vivant
elle ne peut remplir efficacement ses
fonctions que s'il est en bonne santé
certains de ces films d'animation sont
présentés au festival de court-métrage
de Pantin qui propose cette année une
sélection cinéma des armées parmi les
nombreuses pépites du passé on retrouve
une dizaine de films de tous horizons
utilisant les codes cinématographiques
de leur époque
la période qui était retenue pour la
présentation de la sélection au Festival
elle est quand même assez large on parle
de 1915 parce que des années 90 à peu
près une période en fait qui va être
très riche artistiquement parlant on a
beaucoup de films qui vont être produits
et qui va se caractériser notamment par
la présence de jeunes réalisateurs et
cinéastes qui vont faire leur première
arme au cours de leur service militaire
donc typiquement Philippe de Rocca on a
des films avec Jean-Claude Brialy avant
qu'il soit connu on a également des
jeunes premiers Florent Pagny Daniel
Auteuil qui se retrouvent devant la
caméra pour tourner des spots la grande
partie s'adressait essentiellement aux
appelés et aux personnes militaires mais
pas uniquement il y a aussi une partie
des films qui concernait la population
civile qui s'adressait à la population
civile d'où le fait qu'on est et bien
des artistes comme Johnny Hallyday
Florent Pagny qui était leur nom et leur
visage en fait assez assez production
regarde
on est moins dans des films qui
racontent la guerre ou qui filme la
guerre mais des films qui vont
documenter la vie de l'armée que ce soit
à des fins pédagogiques instructives
mais aussi pour accompagner la sortie de
l'armée la réinsertion professionnelle
répondre à des questions à des enjeux de
société
[Musique]
chambre de commerce
icnase
pour nous avoir cette sélection
présentée ici à côté court déjà c'est
une belle reconnaissance de ces de ces
travaux et c'est surtout voilà le
l'opportunité de faire connaître ses
archives un public qui les connaît peu
et puis continuer à valoriser ce
patrimoine
en avril 2019 Notre-Dame de Paris est
victime d'un terrible incendie marqué
par ces images d’horreur le réalisateur
Jean-Jacques Annaud s'est emparé du
sujet pour son nouveau long métrage
l'occasion pour ce grand metteur en
scène de rendre hommage aux soldats du
feu
[Musique]
ce qui est passionnant à raconter c'est
que tout le monde croit connaître tout
sur ce cet incendie en fait personne n'a
été avec les pompiers moi je suis avec
les pompiers pour la défense de ce
monument le plus visité du monde
quasiment mais parce que Notre-Dame est
une star une star internationale et je
raconte un moment où elle va mourir elle
est en difficulté les secours ont du mal
à arriver donc si vous voulez un
potentiel d'émotion et de drame qui est
exceptionnel en plus avec des gens d'une
rare qualité qui sont les pompiers qui
sont des gens qu'on connaît mal qui
finalement décide de risquer leur vie
pour sauver un symbole donc si vous
voulez c'est un sujet
dramatique parfois encore mollesque et
complètement cinématographique le feu
c'est un acteur diabolique et
spectaculaire la plupart des scènes ont
été faits à feu réel et donc et donc
pour nous pompiers évidemment ça nous
parle et en particulier pour les pour
ceux qui étaient sur l'intervention de
revoir les décors à l'échelle une avec
des vrais flammes avec cette vraie
sensation de chaleur c'est évidemment
très impressionnant
la Brigade de Sapeurs-Pompiers de Paris
elle est impliquée je dirais pas sur ce
tournage mais sur ce projet depuis le
début puisque dès les Bauches du projet
des idées on a été associés et les
équipes de Jean-Jacques Annaud ont
d'abord pris le temps de recevoir
individuellement en entretien un grand
nombre d'intervenants de l'incendie de
Notre-Dame pour pouvoir écrire leur
scénario et faire un scénario qui soit
le plus crédible possible on est
intervenu dans énormément de domaines
évidemment le conseil technique le
conseil pour les acteurs pour les
dialogues parce qu'évidemment il fallait
trouver un équilibre entre ce que dit un
pompier ce que peut comprendre un
spectateur qui n'est pas du milieu donc
tout ça c'est fait en étroite
collaboration avec les équipes de
Monsieur anneau et puis évidemment on a
mis à disposition des costumes on a mis
à disposition des engins à la marge on a
aussi mis à disposition un petit peu de
personnel et donc on a été complètement
impliqué à ce projet c'est un film qui
va être très tendu très mouvementé mais
il y a une APN c'est que la cathédrale
est debout et il y a pas eu de blessés
il y a pas eu de mort tous les trésors
ont été sauvés donc si vous voulez c'est
une histoire
particulièrement émouvante
afin d'inciter les créateurs à
s'intéresser au sujet liés à la défense
le ministère des armées s'est doté
depuis quelques années d'un service
qu'il aurait entièrement consacré
le ministère des armées qui est quand
même le second acteur culturel de l'État
on ne le laissait pas assez et très
fortement impliqué dans toutes les
industries culturelles et créatives on
se rend compte depuis la suppression du
service militaire que les Français ne
connaissent pas là l'armée ils peuvent
avoir une idée en avoir une idée
positive ou négative peu importe mais
qui de toute façon n'est plus la bonne
les derniers qui ont fait leur service
militaire ça date de fin des années 90
donc l'armée c'est depuis
professionnalisée et a beaucoup changé
et en fait c'est un désir d'ouverture
l'armée grande muette non c'était
peut-être le cahier à très longtemps
aujourd'hui ce n'est plus du tout le cas
la mission cinéma est industrie créative
est en fait la porte d'entrée pour tous
les créateurs les scénaristes et les
réalisateurs les producteurs les gaines
designers les dessinateurs qui ont envie
de parler de sujets de défense ou d'un
jeu d'enjeux militaire et nous les
mettons en contact avec les experts et
les spécialistes du sujet pour donner de
la crédibilité à la matière et de la
crédibilité à leur récit
en 2015 la série le bureau des légendes
fait une entrée fracassante dans le
paysage audiovisuel français
[Musique]
loin des extravagances de 007 ou des
comédies d'OSS 117 la série traite des
services secrets avec le plus grand
sérieux et là encore aussi surprenant
que cela puisse paraître les auteurs ont
pu rentrer en contact avec les services
secrets de la DGSE
le sujet je crois facile tout le monde
lorsque Éric rochent ma pitié l'idée
initialement il avait envie de pouvoir
raconter dans son style qui est très
réaliste ce que vivent des agents qui
travaillent au sein d'un service au sein
du service de la Direction du
renseignement et au sein de ce service
au service des clandestins quel est le
principe d'alerte si on la perd plus de
3 minutes on estime que ça un enlèvement
on intervient 2 minutes ok
Eric et les auteurs établissent un
protocole qui est
plausible applaudible et si on est amené
à poser des questions à des gens de la
DGSE et ils répondent par plausible ou
pas plausible parce que de toute façon
ils vont pas nous dire plus ils nous
disent vraiment rien mais par contre il
est important pour nous de savoir si on
est dans les clous
l'intérêt est sans doute pour la DGSE
c'est de pouvoir parler sans pouvoir
parler c'est un peu le paradoxe de ce
service ils doivent recruter des gens
formidables et en même temps
ils peuvent pas parler de ce qu'ils font
qu'est-ce que c'est cette histoire de
plan SNCF
et me sortez pas que c'est pour une
preuve de vie
un officier de daesh peut-être essayer
d'entrer en contact avec nous on ouvre
un canal de communication avec lui son
nom de code coaching on était invité à
venir dans un endroit où a été réuni les
directeurs et les 300 agents tirés au
sort pour garder les deux premiers
épisodes de la saison à la fin du
deuxième épisode donc le générique est
en train d'arriver il y a 300 personnes
debout en train d'applaudir les lumières
s'allument mais on est un peu pris de
court des gens de la DGSE nous disent
merci parce que ils ont enfin quelque
chose à montrer à leur famille à leurs
amis ou à des gens qui sont intéressés
qui est réaliste et donc voilà c'est
pour nous ça a été en tout cas pour moi
ça a été un moment incroyable et ça
c'est une fierté
si les batailles ou les grands enjeux
stratégiques retiennent régulièrement
l'attention des scénaristes c'est
parfois le fantasme généré par une
technologie de pointe qui devient le
personnage central de la fiction
[Musique]
vraiment ce pont
nous restons avec les sous-mariniers de
la base de Toulon mais cette fois c'est
pour la réalisation d'une vidéo avec un
youtubeur à succès le major Gérald de la
Légion étrangère qui s'est approprié les
codes de la création numérique
[Musique]
des sous-mariniers donc il y a une
équipe de sous-mariniers qui va bientôt
embarquer pour plusieurs semaines
plusieurs mois et ils ont une
préparation physique qui est assez
spécifique par rapport à leur emploi
parce que pendant plusieurs semaines
voire plusieurs mois donc ils vont être
dans un espace confiné ils pourront pas
s'entretenir correctement physiquement
donc ils ont besoin d'être bien préparé
au préalable même si aujourd'hui ces
vidéos sont parfois visionnées plus de 2
millions de fois le major Géral ne s'est
pas laissé convaincre facilement par la
Légion étrangère
quand tu m'ont proposé leur idée moi
j'étais assez sceptique parce que moi je
suis pas vraiment branché réseaux
sociaux mais je regardais un petit peu
YouTube et je leur ai dit les gars sur
Youtube des vidéos de sport il y en a
profusion on va être totalement noyé
dans la masse difficile de sortir du lot
et ils m'ont bien parlé ils m'ont touché
ils m'ont dit major vous avez un ancien
passé d'athlète vous êtes un sportif
accompli vous avez une personnalité et
faites-nous confiance on va monter
quelque chose ça a marché donc on a eu
du succès on a remboîté le pas sur
d'autres vidéos je me trouve
actuellement dans un endroit totalement
inédit écoutez bien ce que je vais vous
dire je suis à l'intérieur d'un
sous-marin nucléaire d'attaque de classe
rubis
[Musique]
ici on adopte les codes des youtubeurs
les moyens sont légers et le succès est
au rendez-vous
sur les montages on fait pas du
Hollywood vous voyez c'est toujours un
petit peu artisanal quelque part mais
c'est aussi ça ce qui fait le charme de
Youtube c'est à dire que si vous avez un
sujet intéressant même si vous n'êtes
pas très fort en technique vous pouvez
avoir une notoriété donc ça c'est un
caractère très intéressant pour nous
pour la région étrangère on est une des
plus grandes chaînes YouTube du
ministère des armées parce que on a
réussi à conserver notre discours
officiel et on se proposant sur quelque
chose d'autre d'un petit peu décalé le
major Gérald qui a été l'élément qu'on
cherchait pour avoir un nouvel angle de
de communication on est un petit peu sur
sur cette difficulté entre une
communication institutionnelle et
utiliser aujourd'hui les nouveaux codes
pour être audible ça marche bien parce
que aujourd'hui 50% des candidats qui se
présentent dans notre chaîne de
recrutement disent avoir pris
connaissance de ce qu'est la Légion
étrangère à travers la chaîne Youtube en
particulier et puis finalement après
cherchant ils sont tombés sur nos sites
officiels le site Internet les gens
étrangères.com mais également nous
suivre sur notre réseau Twitter sur le
facebook et sur Instagram aujourd'hui
qui est en train de monter en puissance
puisque on joue beaucoup sur l'image
parce que comme nous recrutons
essentiellement des des étrangers et
bien on a la difficulté de la traduction
et finalement l'avantage de l'image
comme de la vidéo c'est qu'elle n'a pas
forcément besoin d'être traduite
outre les réseaux sociaux c'est aussi
vers le jeu vidéo que ce tournoi légion
pour susciter des vocations à l'occasion
du centième anniversaire de son premier
régiment de cavalerie elle s'est
associée à l'éditeur du jeu World of
Tanks pour proposer des chars utilisés à
travers son histoire et collecter ainsi
des fonds pour ses blessés
pour découvrir aussi de passer en fait
de la fiction à la réalité et nous
légionnaires ont aussi ont adoré parce
que finalement c'est aussi un peu notre
premier public parce que sont aussi des
fans de jeux vidéo les joueurs sont
jeunes 26 ans en moyenne et donc ils
adorent aussi les jeux vidéo et donc
finalement ça allait avoir beaucoup plus
de faire un partenariat avec le jeu
vidéo pour eux c'était un peu de se
mettre au grand jour et de montrer un
peu leur métier comme ça à travers
d'autres fans de tanks
le numérique est en particulier la
réalité augmentée ou la réalité
virtuelle sont aussi des outils adoptés
par les différents services de médiation
culturels des armées avec des appels à
projets réguliers et des soutiens
financiers les dispositifs permettent de
moderniser les scénographies des musées
et d'attirer ainsi de nouveaux publics
c'est le cas du musée de Bullecourt dans
le Pas-de-Calais qui a bénéficié d'une
subvention de la Direction du Patrimoine
de la mémoire et des archives
[Musique]
c'est un musée qui relate les batailles
de vulcourt les batailles qui sont
déroulées au printemps 1917 ce sont donc
les troupes britanniques et
australiennes qui ont tenté de faire une
percée sur la ligne d'angle tenue
évidemment par les Allemands
[Musique]
l'accumulation de ces objets seront
émergés du champ de bataille et voulu
voilà pour montrer effectivement la
masse de d'objets qu'on retrouve qui ont
constitué effectivement le quotidien de
ces soldats donc la munition l'armement
l'artillerie et aussi leurs objets
personnels
donc ce musée présente des objets
traditionnels n'importe quel musée mais
ici on a souhaité mettre en place une
vidéo Vulco 360 qui est un dispositif de
réalité virtuelle qui permet de
s'immerger sur le champ de bataille
l'objectif de ce dispositif est avant
tout pédagogique ce qui permet à un
public qui n'aura pas forcément eu le
temps de lire l'ensemble des textes de
s'immerger en six minutes de comprendre
exactement ce qui s'est passé et il est
également attractif voilà pour les
jeunes publics et pour les publics qui
ne peuvent pas se déplacer in situ sur
le champ de bataille
le dispositif permet en plusieurs étapes
de découvrir l'avant bataille le moment
de la bataille où se situe effectivement
le conflit les échanges les tranchées
sont visualisés mais également aussi les
barbelés donc le réseau qui se trouve
juste avant les tranchées allemandes
c'est un dispositif qui est super
immersif quand on sort d'une vitrine où
on a des objets qui sont exposés de
manière un peu plus conventionnelle ça
tranche vraiment avec le reste du musée
et c'est c'est vraiment une nouvelle
manière de d'appréhender l'histoire et
puis les batailles voir sous cet angle
les des champs ou des lieux qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui et de se les
représenter tels que c'était à l'époque
avec des lignes de barbelés avec des
tanks un peu partout ça permet de
s'imaginer vraiment autrement comment
sont déroulés les choses à l'époque
ce dispositif n'est pas un jeu vidéo
l'objectif est avant tout pédagogique il
permet en six minutes de découvrir le
champ de bataille donc pas des fusions
de sang pas d'explosion à outrance c'est
un dispositif pour tous les publics
comme une partition musicale bien
maîtrisée les armées ont appris à jouer
avec les codes artistiques de leur
époque
de manière critique ou de manière
immersive l'art populaire observe
également permanence le féminaire une
chance pour le public mais aussi pour un
ministère qui pourra continuer à
l'avenir à compter sur cette vitrine
pour mieux se faire connaître
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]